اسطوره برشلونه والبرازيل من اضواء الملعب
الى قطبان السجن
لا يعيش اسطوره البرازيل داني الفيج افضل
ايامه حاليا فبعد ان لعب لاشبيليا
وبرشلونه ويوفنتوس وباريس سان جيرمان
ومنتخب البرازيل لسنوات طويله واصبح
اللاعب الاكثر تتويجا بالبطولات في تاريخ
كره القدم بدا يقضي حياته خلف القطبان منذ
يناير الماضي متهما بالاعتداء على فتاه في
ملهى الليلي في الثلاثين من ديسمبر من
العام الماضي هذه التهمه جعلت نجم برشلونه
السابق منبوذا باحد السجون في اقليم
كتالونيا وبعد مرور 100 يوم داخل السجن
تبدو كواليس حياته هناك حزينه للغايه رغم
انه اعتاد المرح طيله حياته البرنامج
الاسباني فيستا تواصل مع احد السجناء من
زملاء الفيج والذي نقل بدوره تفاصيل تلك
الايام التي يعيشها اللاعب خلف القطبان
انفيج يحصل على بعض الامتيازات عن بقيه
السجناء كونه شخصيه عامه ولكنه ياكل من
نفس طعامهم ويعيش حياه قريبه من تلك التي
يعيشونها
يومه خلف القطبان يتلخص في مشاهده التلفاز
اغلب الوقت والبقاء في حاله صمت وعدم
تفاعل مع المحيطين ولا يغادر زنزانته الا
في اوقات ممارسته لكره القدم في المركز
الرياضي السجين الزميل اكد ان النجم
البرازيلي يعاني من حاله حزن دائمه كما
يبدو هزيلا ونحيفا مقارنه بما كان عليه
قبل دخول السجن الفيج كان محبوبا في
البدايه ولكنه بسبب العبارات المسيئه التي
يتلقاها دائما من السجناء والتي تنعته
بالمغتصب بات اقل تفاعلا مع زملائه وحسب
صحيفه
وهو يقوم بتوقيع قمصان كره قدم مهربه الى
داخل السجن للنزلاء مقابل الحصول على
السجائر وكشف احد المصادر انه بالتزامن مع
احد الاحتفالات الشهيره بالبرازيل حصل
الفيج على اله موسيقيه وضلا يعزف عليها
ليلا مما اغضب السجناء الذين ذكروه ان هذا
ليس مكانا للحفلات
فضلا عن مطالبهم التي زادت بسبب
الامتيازات التي يحصل عليها النجم
البرازيلي وكل ذلك بالطبع اغضب اداره
السجن الذي بات في حاله هرج منذ ان احتجز
نجم برشلونه السابق خلف قطبانه وما مرور
الايام تقلصت الزيارات ولم يعد سوى صديقه
المقرب برونو الطباخ البرازيلي الذي ظل
على تواصل دائم مع الفيج طيله الاشهر
الماضيه زوجه النجم البرازيلي وابنه
دانييل وابنته فيكتوريا انتقلوا الى
برشلونه ليكونوا بجواره وتفاجا في زياره
منه في السجن في عيد ميلاده الاربعين
والذي كان في السابع من مايو الماضي ورغم
تاكيد زوجته على ثقتها في براءته الا انها
بدات في اجراءات الطلاق وهو ما يؤكد انه
بغض النظر عن براءته من عدمها فان النجم
البرازيلي يعيش وضعا صعبا على كافه
المستويات وانه حتى في حاله اطلاق سراحه
لن يكون هو داني المرح الذي يعرفه الجميع
على الاقل لفتره يتجاوز فيها تلك الصدمه